welcome everyone to our next episode of
dc thursday
i'm pete from data council and
we're lucky enough to have an awesome
guest today
it's bar moses and barr is the
co-founder and ceo of a company called
monte carlo
in the data quality space
and bar and i are going to have a
conversation about
various aspects of starting a data
company
some interesting things on data
observability and reliability
and some other interesting trends that
she's seeing in the data world
these days including the data mesh and
some other interesting topics
so bar welcome i'm glad you're able to
join us
thanks pete it's great to be here yeah
it's great to have you
um so i just wanted to remind the
audience for those who don't know you
of some of your background
you had an early career that was quite
interesting in the israeli air force and
i read something on your linkedin about
how it seemed that you got into data
even at that early stage in your career
i'm curious if you can
share anything at all about the the top
secret work that you did
um for this for the israeli air force
yeah for sure so um yeah i was born and
raised in israel
um uh actually i lived in the weitzman
institute of science so
very early days i actually like hung out
and my dad's
my dad is a physics professor so i hung
out in his lab
grew weird things in petri dishes and
try to build my own lab and you know not
blow myself up too much
but really just loved physics and math
sort of as a kid
um and then you know what at in israel
at age 18 i was drafted to
um to the israeli air force um and
you're really sort of you know at a very
young age sort of thrown into the real
world right you're given a ton of
responsibility
um for many reasons right one because of
sort of the mission and why are there
uh two because of the people that you
were responsible for
um so as a commander that was
responsible for a group of soldiers
both for their professional and their
personal training
um and you know the third reason is that
um
you know you're actually dealing with
sort of real data that
um that is used by by units in the field
and that's a lot for an 18 year old
right um and it
was a very um you know obviously very
unique experience um we were part of an
eric
reconnaissance unit um so we analyzed
data
um obviously in very different
techniques this was almost 15 years ago
but um you know i think that the impact
of your work is
is very substantial and in a very early
uh
part of my career i learned about the
importance of data quality
and about the power of data to literally
save lives right like that's
that was sort of the mission um and so
that's
you know that was the the some of the
very first experiences that i've had
with data
um and obviously you know the importance
of data quality data reliability
um and and what that means um
uh for for people's lives and for your
impact uh
is very significant that's great and
then from there somehow you ended up
at stanford and i know that you um were
in the stanford research lab for stats
which was
um something you know must have clicked
for you to want to study stats
um i'm curious to hear more about that
yeah so um
uh moved um moved to move to stanford
um which is a lot of fun uh honestly it
was a bit like it felt like disneyland
for my brain
uh you know there were just so many so
many um awesome things to try out
um so many fun things and um just spend
a lot of time sort of with
with math and stats monte carlo
simulations in particular
um and uh yeah just just had a great
experience
it was you know quite quite intense as
well
i have to say but really appreciated
kind of the
love sort of the beauty of math and
having sort of a pen and paper if anyone
remembers the day when you actually like
used a pencil uh to write things um
and uh yeah just just really love my
time there
one of my favorite classes was a class
called mathematics
um where sort of the combination of
magic tricks and and mathematical
algorithms
and one of the the exercises sort of
projects for the class was
um to come up with a trick a magic trick
based on a mathematical algorithm
um there's also a book called
mathematics actually by um the professor
percy deaconess
which i recommend checking out if folks
are curious so what magic trick did you
come up with
i'm i'm dying to know oh great question
i wish i remember it was just such a
long time ago
um i've had to follow up on that um i
actually
actually don't remember okay okay no
problem
well um you also spent some time at
gainsight
and um i think that there's a lot about
that experience that probably affected
the way you've approached
starting a company which i want to get
into later so
um we'll dig in into that part of your
experience in a bit
yeah but um what was it that
specifically
led you to want to start monte carlo
data
yeah so um so i joined game site um uh
uh you know several years after when
sort of the customer success industry
was in its
in its very early days um and was
fortunate to be there against
when we sort of created the the customer
success category
um and uh you know at gainsight
um i built a number of different teams
fortunate to work with great people
and was responsible for the team that um
uh was managing sort of customer data we
basically called it uh gainsight on game
site so we called like
gong for short um and we basically you
know our mission was to become sort of
the best user
of our internal data so that we can
serve as sort of a great example for our
customers
um and you know that meant one
actually becoming data driven as an
organization which i think three to five
years ago we sort of like to say that
but
we didn't actually mean that many
companies you know say that they're data
driven but not truly i think it today
we mean it more like we actually we
actually meet it when we say it
um and so uh that was pretty new for us
actually becoming data driven actually
using data to make decisions
to power new excuse me new products
um and one of the things that was
hardest for me and for my team was that
often times data broke um and by that i
mean
something looked off um first
for you know a number of reasons but for
for some reason
the data looked wrong and we weren't the
first to catch it
actually we were notified about it from
someone else for example someone in
marketing who was using
reports to power a campaign um or maybe
it was
my ceo who was looking at you know usage
patterns for customers
um or maybe it was our cfo who was
looking at sort of bookings or
closed revenue from the quarter um and
oftentimes when
we heard when we heard about these
issues from
other people that was really frustrating
it was incredibly frustrating um
and on top of that once we heard that
there are issues it sort of threw us
into this spin where we basically had to
like
go figure out what exactly went wrong
like did the report not refresh
um you know did someone change the
definition of the field
was someone not using the right field
you know was the table upstream
actually the wrong table to use um was
it a table that should have been
deprecated
was there a source upstream that just
stopped sending information
we didn't know there could be so many
different reasons and so we actually
spent some
you know like detective work to start
unpeeling the onion and like figuring
out where the steps
um and just found ourselves like
spinning wheels on that
um and being you know frustrated by our
inability to to know about these things
before they happen and actually prevent
them to begin with
um and you know i i think when the
situation sort of asks yourself like
am i crazy is the world crazy like how
is there no solution for this how is
this
this is like the way that we we should
be doing this um and i remember sort of
uh
talking about this with my team and
asking like what are we doing wrong here
um and so um that was some some of the
kind of
experiences that gainsight that um led
me to think you know when organizations
are
trying to truly become data driven how
are they managing this right
like are we the only folks that are like
running into these issues or
um you know is there anyone else who's
experiencing that
and was anyone using the term data
observability
at the time not at all actually
not at all um the very first the very
first term actually that we came up with
was
data downtime which was a corollary to
application downtime
and actually i think the very first time
that we tried out that
um that term was in a data council
uh yeah data council conference one i
think this was a few years ago
um and i remember asking that you know
thinking okay we're going to go talk
about dina down time
probably no one's going to care i was
like i'm probably going to show up and
they're going to be like two people
and it's just going to be me and them
and we'll have a great like in-depth
discussion
um and i remember actually being really
surprised by the response
um you know there was good attendance a
lot of people kind of sort of asking
questions and saying
you know this concept resonates like
we've we've experienced data downtime
um you know it's it's uh something that
happens to anyone in data
and it's actually really helpful to have
terminology and language
um to help us describe what this is and
to help us take this to other
stakeholders to
other stakeholders in the organization
to communicate the importance of this
problem
well that's uh that's really personally
gratifying to hear
um i i have to say it seems like there's
lots of founders out there who have
popped up at the conference over the
years
and have tested terms and tested
concepts and tested
marketing spiels um just to see what
resonates with the audience because
as you know there's such amazing people
in our community and we're fortunate to
have
um lots of cutting-edge folks who are
really focused on
the bleeding edge and what the future of
data looks like across all layers of the
stock so
um that's that's really great thanks for
mentioning that because you had not um
specifically told me that before so i'm
i'm really pleased to hear that the the
community in the conference was helpful
and
and in some way validating for you 100
very grateful for that it was
uh yeah the beginning of data downtime
that's great
that's great and so then you kind of
switched a little bit more to
observability um maybe data real do you
talk about data reliability
as well are those are those terms
interchangeable for you or is there any
meaningful
distinction yeah so i think it you know
in in data there's there's a lot of
jargon right so we gotta we gotta
like be careful with you know not
throwing too many words that don't need
much right
uh very well aware of that um the reason
why i
why we use these words is is um because
it's helpful to think about
what the problem is i think if you
define the problem well then it's easier
to define the solution if that makes
sense
and so um i can actually walk through
our thought process you know
when we were thinking through okay data
breaks um
breaks right um why is it breaking there
could be a million different reasons
what's another space or what's another
uh domain
area where something like this happens
oh if you look at application downtime
actually that's a that's a good
corollary let's think through that right
like
applications or infrastructure can break
for a million different reasons right it
could be like a bugs you know an
engineer made a change
so many things can happen um and so you
know what do we do about that we track
that as application downtime
okay cool now um what is a solution
right how do you actually
or like what's the what's the optimal
state optimal state is when you have a
reliable infrastructure reliable
applications
okay how do we get there we get there by
creating observability
into um or reservability around your
infrastructure so that you can get
reliable applications awesome that makes
sense can we apply the same thing to
data why are we not applying the same
thing to data
and if you take that it actually makes a
lot of sense right data can be down you
can get data downtime for a million
different reasons it could be
you know someone made a change which
then resulted in like you know all of
your data
with you know a higher null um
uh percentage than you expect or you
know maybe you know
credit card field turns into you know
suddenly have letters instead of numbers
right um there could be million
different reasons
but in order to make sure that your data
is reliable we need to create data
observability
we need to create help we need to create
a view into the health of your data
to help make sure that you can trust it
um and that's how we actually define
data observability
and um you know in working with our
customers we help them achieve
more reliable data data that they can
trust data that they can use
um you know being able to sleep well at
night and not worrying about waking up
and hearing from your ceo that something
went wrong
in your product or in your in your
dashboard
and you weren't seeing this
functionality being built out in
current apm systems in datadog and new
relic
um what why do you think that is why why
is there a gap there for those companies
and is there anything that prevents them
from getting into the space or
sort of what was your analysis of um you
know why they didn't seem to have
uh data monitoring features per se
yeah so i think there's a few things one
you know the primary users
of apm um you know infrastructure
monitoring application monitoring
are engineering teams right um and data
teams oftentimes
actually uh you know don't use those
solutions
i use different solutions so it's it's a
different persona right it's different
teams with different needs and different
pains
um you know and and um and be and i
think it's very important
uh especially in today's world that
products and solutions
solve problems for particular people
right um
and so designing products with the end
user in mind
what do they care about what do they
wake up um responsible for right
that's a very different perspective or
different product
from the experience perspective so one
very different um uh very different
group of people
that just has different pain points and
coming from customer success
um you know i know how important it is
to start with the
person in mind versus starting with the
solution in mind
so if you start with a technical product
and try to like re-adapt that to some to
someone that's very different than
starting with the persona and their pain
and then you know
truly truly enabling them and empowering
them to solve the data reliability
problem
and then the second thing that i would
say is that um you know what you measure
when you're looking for infrastructure
and app reliability is very different
than what you measure from data
observable
observability which by the way we had to
define right because
it's very clear what to measure in
infrastructure and application develop
observability right like any engineering
team would know what to measure and
would have specific slas and slos for
um you know for uptime but in data
observability
what are you going to measure right
that's not defined
so we actually what we did was um we
spoke to
over 150 or so organizations ranging
from
small startups to large companies like
netflix and uber and facebook
and just ask them like have you had data
downtime what does that look like
what are the main root causes how do you
solve those
um what have you you know what have you
done to deal with that and then we took
all that and we codified that into
what we call the five pillars of data
observability um and those five pillars
uh we believe that if you have sort of
the instrumentation monitoring and
tracking
um of those pillars you can you reach
that sort of um
get a holistic view of the health of
your data and you can trust your data
and so and so you decided to to build
your own product and hence
monte carlo data was born yeah that's
right
um that's right i think for for any
company where
decision making sort of relies on data
or or digital
products rely on data um you know data
trust
is a very important thing like the worst
thing that can happen
is for you to not be able to trust your
data i think we've invested
or we have great solutions and great
ways to collect store process data
we've developed that over the last
decade or so
we have not gotten to a point as an
industry where we know how to use the
data or how to trust it
um and that's you know that's what we're
here to do we sort of call it the
good pipelines bad data problem right we
have great pipelines
awesome infrastructure but the data
itself that's powering it
is actually uh oftentimes wrong
and why do you think it's complicated
for companies to
to address this problem is it a
is it because of a thought process or
assumptions that they make or lack of
tools or
all of the above like what are the key
reasons that that make this difficult
for companies to
to manage yeah i think um you know first
and foremost
this problem is becoming um more sort of
serious and grave
as you know we're relying on more and
more in data so
honestly i think you know uh this isn't
a new problem right like five to ten
years ago this this problem still
existed
um but it was limited in scope and
limited in the number of people that
actually care about it so
you often had you know all of your data
and one data
you know database and you created sort
of an excel report once a quarter and
use that to report financial earnings or
something like that
and you had like a fair amount of people
who could manually like validate that
the data looks right
um and that you can trust it and you did
that like once a quarter
that's a very different reality today in
which organizations are trying to have
you know their building um data platform
teams they have data engineering teams
data science
data analyst teams and on top of that
each of the functions
marketing customer success sales all
those organizations are also becoming
data driven
um so first of all just the sheer amount
of people that have their hands in data
and rely on data has grown immensely
right um
that's one thing that's become really
hard the second thing that's become hard
is just relying on
way more data sources right it could be
like thousands of data sources
um and then the question is you know
even if you sort of
understood that this isn't something
that you want to manage
how do you actually solve this
technically right um so in today's world
just to list out a couple things that
you need to do you know you
have at least two to three if not more
um
data warehouses data lakes bi tools
which you need to instrument um you know
sometimes
many more if in order to do something
like this then you need some scalable
way to actually
process logs metadata and metrics
about your data right everything that
you need in order to create strong
observability
then you need to build some machine
learning to do anomaly detection
and actually fine-tune that so that you
get like a good signal to noise ratio
right so because alert fatigue is a big
deal um for data teams and you want to
make sure that
what you're alerting on is actually
meaningful um
then you need to reverse engineer
metadata and logs actually like build
out lineage
and dependencies across assets right
which is um also its tasks
and so you know it can go on and on
basically like this is just requires
kind of a
um you know a combination of engineering
data science and product work
uh to to build sends and then to
maintain it
um and so uh that's why we we mostly see
um you know folks kind of looking for um
looking for solutions for this once
they've sort of realized that this is
kind of a problem
that can be solved got it
well it's fascinating when when you get
to be in a situation where you're
creating
um helping create a new market and a new
piece of sort of infrastructure
ops tooling um like you are
in this category and um as you and i
have spoken before i think that
it seems that one of your key
superpowers in
in being able to do this was really
sort of learned through the gainsight
process and and as you said before
um being really laser focused on
the customer the user the persona
you know how they're doing it now versus
how they maybe
you know haven't even dreamed they could
do it better
um what were you seeing like in terms of
how the
how the potential customers were solving
the problem
at the moment before before monte carlo
what sorts of solutions were you seeing
yeah so um you know i was
mentioned like really fortunate to be at
game site um and sort of see kind of the
customer success category
uh and come together and the community
come together and have a ton of sort of
lesson learned and
and um you know things that um uh
you know excited to to to bring to monte
carlo and how we work with our customers
today
like customer success is a huge part of
our company um you know not just in the
fact that like we've had a customer
success function from
from day one basically but also that
every
function in the company from product
engineering
marketing sales etc data science is
customer obsessed and is sort of
um you know i can share some examples of
that too but
that's definitely something that's an
extremely important thing for us as a
company
um you know putting our customers first
um to your question specifically what
were people
sort of um doing before kind of like
what how were they thinking about this
before
um there's probably two main ways one is
um like and i assume you're asking how
they were dealing with the data downtime
problem
um and so there were two main ways one
is
actually manually validating data so you
know
something like um you know always having
two to three sets of eyes
on data before anyone uses it right was
super common to do that we did that too
right
we basically had a team where every
morning um someone on my team's name was
bill robbins
uh would wake up and you know basically
validate that the top five to six
um sort of steps in a key transformation
um that was
uh feeding kind of data that executives
were looking at every morning
that the numbers are all like check out
just like quick sanity checks right
um you know i spoke with a chief data
officer at um you know an e-commerce
platform
um company that told me that she would
manually like validate the reports
up until her team was about 30 people or
so or so um
and so super common um that's probably
the most the
sort of the main thing that folks uh
folks have been doing um you know the
other thing that folks
started doing is um um we actually sort
of plot this and kind of uh
we call kind of a maturity curve in
terms of how people started
to deal with this and so the very first
stage is kind of reactive where you
really don't have anything
um uh to deal with this the second is
proactive where you start managing this
and so sometimes
this could be with manual validation and
sometimes it could be with really sort
of basic checks in place
you know just like counting rows making
sure that the number of rows that you
have today is similar to the
number of rows you had yesterday those
are the things that people have started
doing mostly
kind of like bits of pieces um i
mentioned there's like the five data
observability pillars so
i'll just name them but the first is
freshness so i think about kind of like
the timeliness of the data
the second is volume you know so like is
this complete set of data
the third is um distribution so at the
field level
you know um is the data what i expect it
to be in terms of like uniqueness and
null rates etc
the fourth is schema so you know the
structure of the data
fields added removed um and then the
fifth is
uh lineage um so table field level uh
dependencies upstream and downstream
assets
um and so some companies you know start
doing parts of this
um you know row count could be a very
basic example of something under
distribution
that was a long answer to your question
no i get it
and and it seems like um to the the
companies
that were trying to attack this and and
build stuff internally
they'd probably end up with this whole
you know messy
like ball of shell scripts that were
being crowned to run against
you know to do some of these basic
checks and i think we've all heard
stories of that and of course
it's not really a system you know like a
set of scripts like that can be very
unwieldy to manage
um of course over time so uh we can all
see how
that wouldn't scale so um
well that's that's interesting um and
what were the other key like back to the
sort of customer
development process because we have a
lot of founders in our community who are
looking to start new data companies as
well
um what were some of the key insights
that you gained regarding
bringing a b2b product to market in this
space like what were your earliest
um sort of you know steps to engage
customers potential customers how did
you have those conversations and
what did you learn from that process in
case there's insights here that other
folks who are listening can
um can clean from yeah so
um i think in in the early days before
this you know before we even
had a company um you know the very first
thing that
i did and that was the most helpful was
just spend a lot of time with customers
um and spend a lot of time with
customers and learn how to have a
conversation with them that is not
biased which i think is really hard um
there's
this book it's called um the mom test um
bomb test yes great one
for folks who haven't read it uh the
idea there is that
um you know if you take an idea to
know anyone who's close to you and loves
you whether it's your mom your dad
whoever it is
um you know and you ask them like hey
what do you think about this idea i came
up with this idea
and you know they love you and they care
about you so they're gonna be like oh
it's an amazing idea even if it's like
the worst idea in the world
they will still be like amazing you're
the best you should definitely like
start that company
um and that's true for most people who
know you actually as human beings we
tend to get excited and want to help
people
and so the question is how do you choose
people
who actually pass this test and how do
you ask them questions that help them
pass this death um and so at the
beginning i spoke to all these people
like yeah of course amazing idea and i
was like okay definitely not passing the
test here
right are these are these people really
objective
right this kind of exactly yeah right
yeah exactly
is there something unconscious in which
they're you know excited about you
and so they want to be positive um which
can be really confusing as a founder in
the early days right you're like oh
people are so excited
um but actually are they gonna use your
product like this
is it gonna solve something meaningful
for them do they really care about this
i think the thing that like kills
startups
mostly is like when people just don't
care about what you're doing right
um and so you need to find something
that people actually care about they can
you know have strong negative or strong
positive feelings about it but at least
they care
that's the the thing to find um and so
i you know worked hard to find people
who like didn't know me didn't owe
anything um and actually got some like
strong reactions like i remember
you know i had um i like cold called the
cto of of this you know large um
ad tech company and you know showed to
him some like
mock-ups or slides of product and i
remember him telling me like
okay your slides are complete [ __ ]
excuse my language um but the product is
awesome and i would use it tomorrow
and i was like oh interesting what you
know what what an interesting um uh
reaction right um and so sort of
listening really um being sort of in
tune to
what the people that you're you're
asking uh questions of like
what what keeps them up at night um what
do they really care about
um uh what's you know what's the biggest
pain point for them if they had a magic
wand
and they could solve something tomorrow
what would that be um
and so starting with the customer pain
point and not with a technical solution
that you would then apply to that
was one of the the most important thing
um that you know we did
and then speaking to lots of people
understanding their their point of view
and
letting our customers are letting the
market
actually help us define what the what
the problem is from day one was was
really important
so i think it comes back to sort of
customer obsession um
uh from day one that's in in the very
very early stages
yeah i couldn't agree more and um that's
that's a great book i'm glad that you
brought it up i think all aspiring
founders out there should
definitely pick up a copy of the mom
test um
well i want to mention to folks in the
audience that if they have questions for
barr to jump in
in the chat and we'll try to fit your
questions and whether it's regarding
data observability the space
or other things regarding starting a
company please feel to jump in
and so bar i wanted to switch gears a
little bit and talk about another
hot topic in the data world right now um
tell us about the data mesh and what
this means because this is a new term
that's just starting to kind of pop its
pop its head up and i hear folks talking
about it
give us your take on on what the
importance of the data mesh is and
and sort of how folks can be thinking
about that
yeah so um uh data match which i think
that the first
uh it was first coined by um jamaicani
at thoughtworks
um i i love this concept i think it's i
think it's pretty simple which is which
is why it's actually genius
um and it draws actually on some of the
things that we talked earlier about
so you know earlier we talked about how
there are lessons that we can apply from
software engineering to data
and data mesh at its root really draws
around that
right and the corollary here is in
software engineering we've moved from
you know monolith to distributed
architectures and so in the same way in
data
in the past we should have talked a
little bit about this um you know we had
sort of
one big data lake or database with all
of our data um that's not working
anymore today um and so we need to move
from
that sort of approach to an approach
where data is actually distributed and
we have domain specific consumers and
owners of data
and the idea is that when you have
sort of this centralized place to manage
all of your data
it's really hard to do what we're trying
to do which is get everyone in the
company to use data
right it puts a very significant tool on
this centralized team
um you know to uh you know build sort of
all the pipelines run all the queries
support all the data um in this very
very centralized way when actually like
the way that you use data today is very
use case specific
so the way that you're using data and
marketing to drive a campaign is totally
different from how
product and engineering is using your
data to power
um you know uh recommendation algorithm
or
you know how your sales team is using
data to make a decision about a prospect
and a churn analysis for an example and
so the idea that like all the data is
centralized in one place and there's
only sort of
one way to take the data and transform
it and
and then make it accessible is not
scalable at all
and actually makes it makes it very hard
to do what we're trying to do as an
industry which is get more folks to
to use data and to become data driven
and so um
the idea here is that you can actually
um
you you can sort of view data as a
product if you will
where you actually have sort of a
centralized place to
you know align on standards of data um
but then have
you know each sort of domain owner
handle their own data pipelines
their own sort of data outputs if you
will
um and then and let them manage that and
that requires a different architecture
it requires you know
a standardization of communication
around how we do this
um and some self-serve functionality
right
um i think we're you know the idea makes
a lot of sense
to me um i think to many folks in in the
industry
we are early in sort of the the process
um or early as an industry to
to get there um and you know i think
we're i think we're
moving towards there but we're
definitely in the early stages of
figuring out how to apply this and how
to implement this
um for organizations
yeah that makes sense um so
the idea is to basically sort of allow
different
repositories of data to be spread across
the org
um presumably under the care of
different teams that are managing them i
guess that's right there's a
couple things that come to mind there
one is that
um it still seems like there's some sort
of federated governance
access control security
layer that might still be required
and then the second thing is that how
does conway's law
sort of work here where um you know your
organization is basically
sort of your org structure is a mirror
image of the way your
um your tech systems are are built and
so it seems to me that
if we move towards this data mesh
concept
the team the the core data platform team
becomes something that potentially gets
sort of
you know atomized um into the different
parts of the organization have you
have you thought about the org structure
and sort of like what this might mean
from the data mesh perspective yeah i
think
a data mesh actually um mandates
two things when it comes to that one is
you're spot on there has to be
a strong centralized platform team that
does standardize on governance you know
formatting
communication discoverability metadata
right um you need to have that sort of
core
core components
other things that i think this mandates
is you know things like
um you mentioned like security
encryption
uh versioning right um and also
monitoring and quality
and observability right i think those
are things that need to be
adopted as best practices
because when once you sort of
democratize the data
you know you are allowing more degrees
of freedom
and you are allowing more you know more
people
to more consumers um
to use this data and so in a way you
actually need to lie
you need to specify stricter guidelines
um in some sense
and then on the org structure on top of
this um
you know sort of uh centralized group
each domain um each domain specific
uh data consumer data owner that manages
their own data pipelines
need to be equipped with self-serve ways
to manage this right so it's very hard
for someone
it's very hard to expect someone to be
responsible for data
but not help them answer questions like
when was this data last
updated right if i'm if i'm sort of a
uh you know i i own the data for
marketing say
and um you know i don't know where this
data come from came from
when was it updated um who's using it
um when was the last time it was
refreshed uh you know
did it all is it complete those are some
questions that
i need to be able to i need to be
equipped to be able to answer
um in order to do that and so um there
needs to be also thinking around how do
we empower
each of these organizations in each of
these um
you know distributed teams to actually
uh
to support that and it's interesting
because you know in today's
organizations data is already very much
distributed across these teams but the
way that we manage the data is not quite
distributed yet
um and so i think that those are some of
the key
uh parts to enabling um the right
structure and the right um
uh the right sort of people set up yeah
i agree
and uh it looks like our audience is on
the same page because wyatt had just
jumped in the chat and asked us
essentially the same question so
i don't know what well so wyatt i hope
we um answered that
uh to your satisfaction but um
but bar you know another sort of
extrapolation of that then
i think you mentioned it is this whole
notion of the metadata layer
right so the metadata layer becomes even
arguably more important and even this
term metadata layer is kind of a new
thing that's being tossed around now by
various projects it seems like it's even
more important in this data mesh
world talk to us about how you think the
metadata layer and the data mesh
play together and and why those maybe
those are two things this time
this time has come yeah it's like the
rise of metadata now
um right um
you know i think uh in it's a ninja it's
interesting right
because um you know in the last five to
10 years we've sort of
seen the rise of data i think people you
know call like the next decade the
decade of data
um and we've gotten really good at sort
of collecting aggregating
um and storing data um we we actually
have
might someone might say too much data
and we're not sure how to use it um
now we're getting all excited about
metadata and now we're like let's
collect all the metadata we can
extract everything you know um uh
you know go all in on metadata and then
the question is a little bit like okay
what do we do with it now right um so i
have this like beautiful map of lineage
and i know all of my assets
um and i can understand how all the
tables relate to each other and they
all connect together and that's awesome
um you know
what am i supposed to do with this now i
showed it to my manager and you know
she got excited and and we moved on um
uh so uh you know i think there's a risk
sort of with this kind of like metadata
um
uh theme is that we we collect a lot of
and actually not put it
not put it to good use i think it's
awesome we use it i actually think it's
great because
in the in recent years we can
actually um automate a lot of the
metadata collection so in the past it
was
you know in order to to create sort of a
view of your lineage
table level dependency you had to
actually manually map it out
um so you had to like you know tap the
shoulder of you know your
friendly data engineer data analyst and
ask like hey
like what are the data sources that are
you know you know um
feeding this table and you know all
those questions and today
you can actually um extract that
automatically
so that's a great advantage that helps
us get more metadata but i think the key
here
is actually applying metadata
to a particular use case going back to
sort of what we talked about like
starting with the customer pain point if
i'm the data team that's responsible for
um you know enabling other people in the
organization to use data
how about how are they going to use
metadata or how should how should our
data team actually use data
what are we going to do with lineage for
example and so lineage actually becomes
powerful when
you can you want to ask questions like
you know um
i'm going to make a change a particular
table here uh or a particular field or
i'm going to
i want to deprecate this table is anyone
going to care
right is there anyone downstream who's
looking out and and
listening or you know like uh are using
this table
maybe maybe there's like zero downstream
dependencies and i can just deprecate
the table it's not a big deal
um but maybe there's like thousands of
uh dependencies and
lots of users querying it every day and
in that case a change can be
way more impactful so once you actually
use uh metadata or lineage
for a particular business question i
think that's where the power of metadata
actually
lies and i think we'll see more and more
powerful applications of metadata
when they are applied to particular pain
points that we have in the data industry
we have a lot of pain points there's a
lot of things to solve and i'm excited
to see how we we apply better use
of the combination of data and data
about our data
to solve some of these problems yeah i
agree i think the metadata layer needs
to power
specific use cases applications on top
of it
for it to be really meaningful which is
why
a lot of the companies in our in our
community um are working on sort of
you know appointment solutions of
applications that and they sort of end
up backing into the metadata
implementation manifestation of their to
power their own product
i think it's been interesting now to see
a couple companies that are popping up
and trying to go at it from
the bottom up um so you know we'll see
like where
where we all meet in the middle and how
that happens but um it's definitely a
new and interesting space and i think
there's there's a lot to watch out for
that's exciting there
we have it we have another question uh
rich is asking
data mesh as a concept relies
heavily on undistributed sources does
this imply architecture where
source data remains in place or is a
virtualized architecture possible
do you have any thoughts on
virtualization as it applies to
the data mesh yeah great question um
you know i actually i never got that
question i probably have to think about
that
um you know i think in terms of um
how we how we think about the structure
of um
sort of the architecture itself um you
know
the i think the most important thing is
to think about
um you know how do you abstract some of
the problems from
um uh how do you abstract the problems
from your the data consumers themselves
and so if you have sort of the
centralized platform
um that is a line on some of these
standards
um then you can you can definitely
empower your data consumers to focus
only on their um you know
on the use cases that they care about
and that means the sources that they
rely on in particular
and maybe not all the sources that um
that feed sort of the data platform
um but it's a good question yeah maybe
maybe something for us to
watch out for um as the whole data mesh
um
situation evolves yeah i think there's
actually a need for
for more and more kind of um you know
folks trying out
and um you know experimenting with this
and building
more of this sort of data mesh
architecture
and so i'm really really eager to see
more folks contribute to this in
in the space and um on the lookout for
some great examples
so if folks want to share or contribute
or even collaborate would love to hear
from people
yeah absolutely and it looks like wyatt
has a follow-up question
um on data mesh how do you think the
data mesh is different
from something like kimball's data mart
is this another
pattern occurring in the industry where
we cycle between distributed versus
centralized well
isn't everything a pattern in the
industry where we're cycling between
distributed and centralized um but uh
but maybe you have some other thoughts
there as well bar yeah
so the you know it's a great question
because
that's maybe one thing that we see
that's constant this
you know uh sort of oscillating between
distributed and centralized and
and we see that with organizations it's
it typically actually follows
um it follows up a company's
uh sort of journey in um in
what we call their data life cycle so in
the very early days
it is more common to have a centralized
team
that um you know is responsible for uh
for all of your data needs especially as
an organization is small or a company is
small
um and then you know there's this point
where the company sort of organization
becomes bigger and then suddenly there's
a need for more
um uh for more support for the different
data consumers and so then you start
seeing
data analysts and data scientists being
embedded within
each of these teams um and so that
um uh you know sort of moving to more
distributed
and then you know as the company
continues to grow and mature
then suddenly um you know there's this
like oh [ __ ] moment where like ah it's
sort of a mess
you know we've tried to democratize data
we let everyone sort of run free with it
we got to like reining in
and then there's sort of a centralized
team back again um
and then you know i think i think this
sort of you know continue to oscillate a
little bit as a
as organizations change um i think you
know the data mesh again
is as a concept is um is when the sort
of product probably brings the best of
both of those worlds
but we need to see more examples of it
um in the wild if you will
uh um yeah yeah agreed it's still early
days for sure
yeah um so someone else is asking a
monte carlo question
ooh maybe maybe we'll we'll get an
expose on some up-and-coming features of
monte carlo if we
play our cards right let's see uh
alessio is asking
do you see monte carlo expanding towards
ml monitoring
ml model monitoring model monitoring in
the future
yeah great question um so uh
so definitely you know if i think about
the category right um
i think about like data observability
data reliability it certainly spans the
problem of
um ml monitoring for sure right like um
if you want to uh sort of try
trust your data wherever it it is it
doesn't matter if it's uh
in your product in your bi solution um
in a machine learning model
uh whatever it is so i think in order to
achieve real data observability or real
um reliability of your data it has to
include
um you know your machine learning uh
products as well
um uh you know for for us in particular
uh you know we
sort of think about the reliability of
the data powering that
and we do support that uh but i think
you know again going back to sort of the
the the category and what we need to
figure out as an industry
i think that requires sort of powering
your data wherever it is
got it it seems like in the ml model
monitoring world um
there's sort of a whole new set of types
of ways
the model can go awry
it can be skewed or there can be drift
or it can be
biased and there can be all kinds of
things that
may or may not map directly i mean i
guess everything ultimately maps to the
training data
but i'm sure you've thought of this
there might be sort of additional
expressions
required to be able to sort of cover all
the different ways a model could go
wrong
that um are very nuanced when it comes
to
you know other null checks or freshness
checks
in in you know the the origin data
itself so
i'm curious to hear um you know as your
product develops um
how you how you think of that in the
future yeah most definitely um
i think the you know this is something
that we sort of are evolving with our
customers right uh
sort of going back to uh to um sort of
customer obsession
obsession um as our customers are as
we're seeing more and more organizations
use machine learning
um you know deployed in production um
you know we
sort of plant it to you know obviously
support them and and their needs but
you know i think one of the interesting
things here is kind of the the bias
point that you mentioned and there's
more and more work on that um
which is interesting too curious if um
you know maybe that's top of mind for
folks but
um that those are one of the areas that
i'm seeing more interesting things um
come up um you know i think it's this is
another area where it's the early days
similar to data mesh data
observabilities
and its uh in its beginnings um and so
we're defining that and
we're defining what that means
especially in models so
um you know i'm excited to see to see
where we take this as an industry
yeah that's great um well bar it's
really great to have you
in the community and have you in the
space and building a company i really
respect what you guys are up to
um and this has been a fun conversation
i i just wanted to ask you
as the sort of close um what's
what's the thing that surprised you most
about your work in the data ecosystem so
far
hmm that's a great question um
i think probably the thing that i've
been
um most amazed by is
um sort of the strong reception actually
of um
of both this problem and the solution
sort of data ability
um you know the responses that we get
from the community whether it's from
back then that conference that you know
that talk the data downtime that we you
know had data council
a few years ago back to sort of you know
customers today who
um you know we're able to uh to bring
real value to and to solve
um their lives you know when when we
kind of uh
are able to help them you know sort of
catch an issue before anyone else does
or find a bug uh you know before it
impacts
uh production uh or better yet actually
like help them prevent issues to begin
with um
those are some of the things that sort
of get me excited to to wake up in the
morning and
and i've been surprised by the strong
reactions um from people
uh and and um you know by how how
quickly
um you know folks are adopting the
concepts of data observability
and data reliability and i've been uh
been really impressed by how fast
we're um you know as an industry
adopting these
these concepts these concepts yeah it's
great as a founder when
you step into a emerging market that's
really
that really needs a solution that you
have to offer and so
um i know there's there's there's no
other feeling that's quite like that
so um congratulations on finding that
and we look forward to
seeing how you and the company develop
going forward
thanks and um thanks again for the the
data council uh community
it's uh we have a sweet uh spot you know
soft spot in our heart
um uh for the community and so thank you
yeah
we're looking forward to getting people
back together irl
as soon as we can for sure um just so
that you know folks come to me every
week and
ask when the next conference is going to
be and um
we're anxiously um awaiting the the time
that we can announce that
so just a heads up yeah you want to stay
healthy until then
yeah absolutely um so i just want to
make a couple of quick
comments and uh announcements um
afterwards
first of all we're really grateful to
have ibm
who's been a sponsor of dc thursdays
since we launched they've been
supporting us behind the scenes um
they're a big supporter of open source
software
and you can check out their data science
community online which has some great
resources
open source and other content for data
professionals
so make sure to check out the ibm data
science community
and also don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel and that way you'll
get notifications of our upcoming
episodes
um speaking of upcoming episodes i'm
really excited to have jennifer pren key
on with us next time
on february 18th she'll be talking about
active learning
jennifer is one of the the most leading
foremost researchers in active learning
um in the world and she's starting a
company around active learning so we'll
be excited to
to chat with jennifer in about two weeks
and then finally
leave us comments if you have a minute
we'd love to hear what you're thinking
i have office hours scheduled i think
there's a couple slots open
if founders want to chat about starting
a data oriented company i'm happy to
help them out any way
that i can and you'll find all these
links in the chat bar
on the right